well Google is policing the content
posted to YouTube and they're using a
thoroughly discredited left-wing group
to do that Google has creating a group
of trusted flaggers who will help the
company monitor alleged extremist
content on the website one of those
trusted flaggers is not trusted at all
it's the Southern Poverty Law Center
it's not an expert on the south or
poverty or the law john stossel recently
explained the truth about this group in
an amazing report here's part of it the
Southern Poverty Law Center based in
that building in Alabama calls itself
the premier group monitoring hate groups
looking at their map of such groups
you'd think America was consumed by hate
I once believed in the Center's mission
well-meaning people still do Apple just
gave them a million dollars but what
donors don't know is that today the
center smears people who don't deserve
to be smeared the Southern Poverty Law
Center now lists people like Ben Carson
Laura Ingraham and Jeannie puro as
extremists but it doesn't list antifa
the hate group that beats up people on
the right the center's become a hate
group itself it's now a left-wing
money-grabbing slander machine it's a
hate group it is a hate group too let's
just be honest about that Eric Sheffer
is a tech entrepreneur new joins us
tonight Eric you follow this stuff
closely how did the Southern Poverty Law
Center which is wholly discredited and
wholly political wind up policing
content on the most powerful company in
the world have that happened you know
it's hard to understand I think what was
going on
tucker is that these you know YouTube in
essence was trying to be inclusive in
their mind and really trying to have an
optical perspective that they were being
and doing everything they could because
they were taking a lot of heat from
people saying they weren't doing enough
to stop Isis and extremist groups right
so that's what led to this but it's just
too far I mean you know I can't imagine
how they can have this group and really
in my opinion more should be done and
a lot more so I mean for people watching
at home who think that your southern
property lost in our sounds like a
legitimate group give us an example of
the people or movements or websites they
have deemed out you know beyond the pale
haters extremists who they called that
well I mean Laura Ingraham ben Carson I
mean you know so you've got conservative
figures that ya are labeling and I think
it's gone too far really in my opinion
that YouTube should fire Southern
Poverty immediately from all YouTube
monitoring because it's an outrage I
mean to have the possibility of an anti
conservative hitting delete for partisan
reasons or on any content that's
relevant patriotic Americans and I think
Google really needs to be and YouTube be
transparent I mean moving forward to
monitor content and have a militant
policy related to anyone that has any
political affiliation or any reputation
for being partisan and I think also
there really needs to be an apology to
patriotic Americans that use YouTube for
this gross oversight and unfair
processes that's really done not with
any kind of disclosure in the choice of
using Southern Poverty for monitoring of
content it's just it just doesn't make
sense and frankly it opens up a bunch of
things I mean when they're doing that
service what else are they doing it to
well that's a great question we don't
know because of course it's totally
opaque and by the way whatever happened
to saying what you think is true even if
people don't like it but I guess that's
passe Eric thank you it's great to see
you tonight
Thank You Tucker